well Wall Street has wall street has
already had something like 30 or 40,000
layoffs and they're more coming so Wall
Street is going to retrench for sure for
a while investment banking has has
slowed down and one of the one of the
consequences of the problems in credit
markets has been that a lot of private
equity the big blockbuster private
equity deals have dried up a lot of them
will now have not been completed and
won't be completed so there is a there
is a problem there I think but at the
same time there are other people on Wall
Street who make money from restructuring
from they make money from turnarounds
bankruptcy turnarounds so people in that
business or that part of Wall Street are
very happy they're doing well we expect
to see more bankruptcies in the
corporate sector we expect to see more
turnarounds more workouts and so they're
they're always investment bankers happy
to work in those kinds of deals
I think it will be on its way back a
year from now but slowly I think it will
take a while for these credit problems
to work themselves out of the system in
part because a lot of people don't
understand all of the issues that are
out there there are other kinds of loans
besides mortgage loans that that are
potential sources of problems student
loans are a problem area that is now
beginning to make headlines so well the
student loan industry grew in much the
same way that the mortgage industry grew
that is there were lenders willing to
make loans their government agencies
willing to that would guarantee them and
then these loans would get securitized
packaged wrapped as they say they would
be insured and then sold to as
investment vehicles for for lots of
people around the world now the problem
is that the one of the most important
companies that insured these loans went
out of business and the market for
selling the securitized loans have just
disappeared you can't sell them now so
there is a lot of talk about whether the
government is going to step in and buy
them because if you know it's just like
a bank it needs to sell these things in
order to have more money to lend and so
there are lots of concerns now that that
they can't be sold that eventually banks
are going to want to get out of this
business